[Music]
Jeff Snyder here at the Kia telluride
supper suite in Park City and I am here
with the team behind the very very funny
comedy the climb we've got Mike Covino
Gale Rankin and Kyle Marvin thanks for
coming in guys
so there is a trailer out for this night
and I if you're watching at home go
watch the trailer because it very
effectively communicates the premise of
this movie but for those who haven't or
whoever watched it Mike let me explain
what this movie's actually about okay so
the basic concept was based on a short
that Kyle and I made 2018 and the the
idea was simple it was two guys are
riding bikes up a hill one of them is
out of shape because he just went
through a breakup and the other ones in
shape and he reveals to him that he's
sleeping with the others X and so Kyle
starts chasing me up the hill but he
can't catch me because he's out of shape
and so and it's all done in one shot so
you're sort of struggling and watching
these guys start up the hill so with the
feature we basically just took that
scene and expanded upon it and then
followed the journey of this friendship
over the next 13 years or so while they
continue to kind of go through the same
cycle of of destructive behavior and
Kyle continues to forgive my character
of things and can you guys take me
through the journey of how you actually
expanded the short lake so the short
plays 2018 Sundance who's Cesar's who's
that influential person who's like this
is actually a feature and gives you that
opportunity to I mean we came we came to
with the short knowing there was a we
had a good take on the future already so
we kind of came prepared when we had to
short yeah we literally spent our entire
festival pitching and pitching and
pitching hoping for someone to jump on
board and at the end of it we had a
couple opportunities and we went with
topic studios who give us a great great
yeah
and so Gail why don't you tell me how
you got involved and what attracted you
to this project and working with these
two jokers well you know you use the
right you can have my tea
hey I'm sick you know I I read the
script and it was extremely unique and
and I'd heard from casting directors
Jess Kelly and Rebecca Dealey who are
incredible at Christie Street casting
they they were really enamored with boys
and with the script and super funny
extremely original like has definitely
like it's very much up my alley in terms
of like its it's an art how see in the
file film but also has like a very kind
of mainstream II ish comedy not
mainstream actually like very highly
sophisticated mainstream comedy and so I
was really attracted to when I read it
and and then these guys it was just like
it was a no brainer we we facetimed when
I was like upstate doing a experimental
Chekov play and then we met in the city
really could have been a regular check
off playing we would have cast her but
it was experimental so we were really
they were on board that was that was I
was playing her to gas dynamics were
already explained audition she was
really sitting in an apartment in
Brooklyn yeah sorry I was just like
doing this weird thing I just like
spawns really I loved your character
because I've been the boyfriend where
the family doesn't really like him tell
me about tonight's simulcast cuz I don't
know if it's the first that summons has
ever done it is okay according to Cooper
John Cooper who said this is the first
like cuz they could go and watch this
tonight if they want they don't even
have to be here totally if you're in
Tempe Arizona or Buffalo or Philadelphia
or Cambridge message I'm not gonna do
that
there's 10 cities around the country
look it up on Sundance website but yeah
tonight we're playing around the country
and so basically what it is is they're
gonna play the movie at the same time
and then they're simulcasting the Q&A so
that like will be
they'll be live listening to a Q&A
happening in the audience that is it
great it's a great way for independent
cinema to really get out into
communities that wouldn't always get to
see them in this format so I think it's
really it's really cool we're excited to
be part of it
and then you guys don't know who you're
sitting here with but I am the world's
number one Todd berry super fan he goes
wait work it's so funny we were doing we
recast Todd berry we were in like way
upstate New York and we started this
Dyke this comedy or this restaurant next
to a comedy club and he was on the
billing and we were like Todd are you
are you playing here like next week he's
like yeah yeah yeah I'm here next to me
exactly but he was shooting with us five
times he's had absolute best I mean Todd
is like you can't really fully
communicate his personality and I
thought I understood dry humor until I
met Todd berry in person and then I was
just like oh you're taking this to a
whole different level of like like just
comments that I'm like did you did you
say something I was like oh no that was
one of the funniest jokes I've ever
heard I think he sets up jokes and pays
them off like four years later can you
guys tell me about the dynamics of your
actual friendship like how'd you meet
have either of you ever like you know
betrayed the other and had to beg for
have I slept with his wife
have you known each other how did you
meet that kind of thing yeah we met in
New York on working in commercials I
actually I cast him in a commercial job
and then we hit it off so well that we
started a commercial production company
together that was like ten years ago
what's the writing process like between
you guys there's a lot of fighting as it
should be no it's not this is the
writing process and this was great
because we we would take the scenes if
you put them up in an acting class so we
would like we we'd write all day and
then we would take the pages and we
would go for three hours and then at the
end of the class we would like put up
the scene and we would try it then we'd
come back the next day and we'd like
make it was like this really fun sort of
theater process where we were like just
work shopping and getting into the place
that we wanted to
because we were acting in it we kind of
had the luxury of like really testing
out the material before we went into
production the chemistry definitely
shows on screen this film played it it
can tell you're at Toronto now Sundance
I have to ask was just not good enough
to get into Venice guys you know I asked
myself the same question every night
when I go to bed is the film festival
circuit being like for you know with
this movie I mean they're all different
and in amazing ways it's just been a
constant surprise so like you know any
of them if we played you know a regional
festival we would have been if we
premiered at Woodstock we would have
been stoked is this one special because
the short debuted here yeah it's special
because the history of American
independent comedy like this is this is
the spot where that stuff happens and
like there's this heritage of American
comedies that are being made like
independently that are outside the
studio system that exists here and
that's just a really cool thing to be
part of yeah I think when you're a
programmer you take a chance so they
took a chance on the short and not and
and and coming back here at the future
feels like right we wouldn't have made
the movie if we didn't have the shorter
liked it just never would have happened
we wouldn't have had the opportunity
there's no chance we would have stopped
everything we were working on and doing
to go try and make the feature of this
if we didn't have a short hair Gail I'm
a big Glo fan I love the show are you
going to be checking out your co-stars
movies I saw Sunita last night last
night I'm exhausted
Sunita last night and I'm gonna go to
Ali's after-party it's been it's just
easy
um schedule here but I don't know if I'm
gonna get to see the actual movies but
I'm gonna definitely get into that
promising young woman tonight it was
wild I owe you saw it Chris I just came
from it with Chris and Alison Oh amazing
amazing yeah and and Ali's maybe horse
horse girl that's right that's right
yeah which is also super exciting she
purchased it yeah and like you just
wrapped working with Tom Hanks and Paul
Greengrass is that right on news of the
world I did yes what is it just a small
of a small part well how do you figure
into that one I don't even understand it
still I was out in the desert in Santa
Fe shooting for a month riding horses
and shooting guns with
I'm is me I play villain oh really yeah
yeah it was a villain but now I'm
looking forward to it yeah it was one of
the coolest things I've ever done is a
big surprise it was just like a thing
that I auditioned for and got and and
was like I'm gonna go do this to the
best of my ability so it's awesome I
think it comes out Christmas this year
and what does the climb come out March
20th it's be a sony classic yeah March
20th in in probably just like select
cities and then nationwide the following
week so the 27th it should be everywhere
and what are you guys working on next
are you writing something else together
yeah what we wrote a TV show together
which there's a chance we're gonna go
out try to sell soon but we're writing
our next movie together it is it's it
explores like relationships between
parents and kids is that is this the
quench that's only I'm be paid before
that we did this under wraps no title
yeah the quench we're producing and we
should we're gonna be making this year
yep I'm Kyle wrote that okay and I'm
just a humble producer all right to your
next collaboration or if you're you know
in one of those select cities check it
out tonight via the simulcast thank you
to Kia Telluride supper sweet for
hosting us thanks for coming in guys
you